c'est que on est le pays où l'ascenseur
social est effectivement en panne avec
un ressenti très fort et on est le pays
qui dans le monde et le plus
redistributif ses marges home nous avons
56% depuis quittant distribution
redistribution mais la redistribution
bon sang de bonsoir ça sert unis ça sert
principalement à essayer de réduire les
inégalités
or il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
bien que ceci ne va pas dans la machine
redistributive
il ya des pertes en ligne il ya des
pertes en ligne et puis il ya il ya un
mauvais procès ce qui fait que que ça
vous ça vous ça vous colle des gens dans
une situation qui m'a l'éducation
nationale c'est vrai l'éducation
nationale ne fonctionne pas et ne
remplit pas sa mission
je je je pense par exemple à une forme
cela fonctionne comme dans l'éducation
nationale
le système de la carte scolaire mais ça
a été une connerie monumentale parce que
ça vous à savannah scotché des gens dans
l'école où il habite alors qu'il aurait
fallu faire circuler les gens pas mal
quand on a appris des mois je me
souviens j'étais de mettre des
universités un peu partout dans l'est
dans les dents dans les départements au
plus près des familles
c'est une bêtise il faut qu' il faut que
les jeunes puissent circuler pour aller
dans une autre région
il aurait mieux valu cher à circuler il
fallait consacrer l'argent à autre chose
et assurer la mobilité à des cités
universitaires etc maintenait ces
inégalités dans un livre on a maintenu
ces inégalités et on s'est pas préoccupé
de ce qui a été la véritable cause de
2,2 de la panne de l'ascenseur social
c'est la capacité de trouver un emploi
c'est des jobs c'est le job qui vous
sort de deux de cette misère sociale et
de ce déclassement social
donc on s'est laissé avoir par par le
déclassement liés à la perte des emplois
industriels
et puis on s'est laissé avoir aussi par
l'impossibilité de permettre à
l'entreprise d'embaucher plus facilement
la série de réformes qui a été fait
depuis dijon françois hollande ou
peut-être un peu avant même même au
moment de la crise par rapport sarkozy à
débloquer la seule la chose les
résultats ont tardé les résultats sont
en train d'apparaître